last night I was standing there looking
at a monitor on one camera was Linda
Hamilton and on another camera Arnold
Schwarzenegger I thought holy [ __ ] I'm
making a Terminator movie then let's
recapture that tone
it's r-rated it's gritty its gritty it's
fast
it's intense look hard and play hard and
this movie was all about Jane Estes
fresh vision and like what he did in
Bedford his action is it's just a fast
white-knuckle ride you better watch your
ass I hunt terminators metal
[ __ ]
but follows tonally in the footsteps of
t1 and t2 that adrenaline rush feeling
that sense of terror in this film the
action is ten times bigger it's like
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] this film
is relentless it just does not stop
just [ __ ] insect
you
two days ago I had this nice simple life
I know it's a nightmare
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
my name is Sarah Connor never seen one
like you before
almost human
I am human
well you care what happens to her
because I was her
now do we win we win by keeping you
alive
I'm going hunting
[Music]
you